what is right about this time well
so many things um
that were on the other side of a lot of
a lot of the life experience that's
happened and also that we have
the ability to make our own choices in a
way that
i couldn't have said yes to you then
meghan markle is ready to talk
on friday a new sneak peek from the duke
and duchess of sussex sussex's
highly anticipated 90-minute tell-all
with oprah winfrey dropped
and lady-o revealed this wasn't the
first time she tried to sit down with
meg
back in 2018 before the couple tied the
knot
oprah said she called megan personally
to ask if she could interview her and
harry
you said i'm sorry it's not the right
time
and finally we get to sit down and have
this conversation
i remember that conversation very well i
wasn't even allowed to have that
conversation with you personally
right there had to be people from the
comp sitting there around
everything there were other people in
the room when i was having that
conversation
you turned me down nicely and said uh
perhaps
there will be another time when there's
the right time and megan says
the right time is now we're on the other
side
of a lot of a lot of the life experience
that's happened and also that we have
the ability to make our own choices in a
way that i couldn't have said yes to you
then that wasn't my choice to make
she goes on to imply that buckingham
palace had extreme control over her
actions
and the things she said as an adult
who lived a really independent life to
then go into this
construct that is
different than i think what people
imagine it to be
it's really liberating to be able to
have
the right and the privilege in some ways
to be able to say yes
and to say that to yourself not to have
to consult with anybody
at this point yeah to be able to just
make a choice on your own and just be
able to speak for yourself
this new clip comes just days after an
article was published by the times
claiming that megan bullied her royal
aides
the times newspaper has reported that
the duchess allegedly bullied
two members of her household staff out
of kensington palace
and made the life of the third member of
staff almost unbearable
and those are the allegations they are
strongly refuted
by the duchess of sussex who says she
didn't bully anyone
out of the palace a spokesperson for
megan and prince harry has denied the
allegations
in a statement to e.t calling it a quote
calculated smear campaign
based on misleading and harmful
information
megan who is a spokesperson for women
around the world who
who claims in her own statement and has
spoken very publicly about
being the subject of bullying she's
talked about online bullying and
trolling
and being bullied in the media now
having to fend off claims
that she in fact has been a bully
following the allegations buckingham
palace announced they're launching
an internal investigation while i think
it's very unlikely that the palace
is behind this because this this doesn't
serve them well either
clearly there is a member of staff or a
former member of staff who
is disgruntled and who wants to have a
different
version of events put out there but on
thursday
some of megan's closest friends and
celeb pals
came to her defense suits writer john
cowan described his experience working
with her on the
series tweeting that she was a warm kind
caring person while one of megan's
college friends lindsey roth
wrote in part quote meg's mo has always
been kindness
goodwill runs in her bones i know this
to be true
after 22 years of very close friendship
janina gavankar tweeted that the duchess
is quote kind
strong open and jamilah jamil
also spoke out asking on twitter if this
is what the royal family is comfortable
doing to a heavily pregnant woman
publicly
can we even imagine what they put her
through privately
they seem terrified her interview hasn't
even aired yet
what are they covering up the stench of
their desperation
is rotten